hello and welcome to shut up and talk I
am Doug Walker our very first guest
actually spent a good chunk of her
childhood on screen you may remember her
from unforgettable films like mrs.
Doubtfire Miracle on 34th Street and
Matilda and some other films we like to
forget like a simple wish and Thomas the
Tank Engine and she also spends her time
totally schooling me because I made
comments like that on nostalgia critic
she is a very awesome lady we are
incredibly happy to have her here as our
very first guest mara Wilson say hi
Maura Hey I have to say I notice you
have boobs how's that working out for
you even the rest of the Internet yeah
because there does seem to be the
strange understanding that child actors
do not in fact grow up so is that
something where you see people doing a
double-take
I've got well well what surprises me
most I mean when people are like hey
you've got boobs now you know I'm just
like well yes yes I do
but what really surprises me are the
people who say my childhood is ruined
because you have boobs now like I am
actually the catalyst of this I actually
I have kind of a funny story about that
my my dear friend Andrew we did an
audition together in college where there
was a love scene and we had to make out
and get very physical with each other
and the director was like are you okay
with doing this are you okay with doing
this and I was like yeah I'm fine and
Andrew said that was the precise moment
that his childhood ended yeah he was
like oh god oh god do I have to feel
Matilda up and this I don't think we
actually went that far but the director
was just like are you okay if we do this
and you know it's it's NYU so you kind
of have to say yes you almost wonder
what the Harry Potter kids go through I
me because their fans had to literally
watch them develop private parts pretty
much yeah exactly like like Thomas I was
such I was I was at such an awkward age
and Thomas all the photos of me at the
time were are just awful it's kind of
like having you know the entire world
see your middle school yearbook when
someone tells me or it's almost to tell
someone your Amarra Wilson I mean
obviously people could see it but do
people recognize
as you not knowing the name or not
knowing that you are in fact Mauro
Wilson like do people recognize you on
the street or not we do sometimes I get
a lot from young retail people really
I'll go into a Jamba Juice or I'll go
shoe shopping and you know the girl
behind the counter is 19 years old and
she look at me funny and be like you
know you look like the girl from Matilda
I'll be like yeah I get that a lot
because I do it's kind of embarrassing
when people make a fuss it's like oh oh
yeah I get I get shy suddenly I've had
people come up to me before saying is
your name Matilda and I'll say no and
they'll just walk away very disappointed
to just walk away but it's a sort of
this age group that does it this age
group I guess they grew up with Matilda
but also most people in New York really
don't care that's that's one thing I
like about living in New York is nobody
cares they're just like oh well okay
that's who you are you know we got Susan
Sarandon and we got much more famous
people you know coming into our deli
every day do you have people who come up
to you say are you Matilda yes you
ruined my childhood by having boobs yeah
not yet not yet but but I'm it's only a
matter of time it's it's only a matter
of time obviously the whole acting
career I mean it's what you're best
known for how did you in fact get into
that or actually was it even your choice
to get into that being a child star oh
it was my choice I'm one of the few
child actors who actually decided that's
what I wanted I was five years old
and my oldest brother had done a little
bit of acting just bit parts in in tiny
movies and my mom used to say that he
did big parts and small movies and small
parts and big movies and he doesn't do
that at all now but I I saw what he was
doing and I was always making up stories
and performing them they were like epic
poems I would sing them and I loved to
perform so I said that I wanted to go on
auditions I went up to my mom and I said
mommy I want to do what Danny does and
she said no you don't they actually
tried to discourage me my parents tried
to discourage me but then after
explaining the concept of rejection to
me they decided to let me go on a few
auditions and then I was cast in a
Lunchables commercial and I was cast and
a few other commercials I think and then
I got called for a movie which was mrs.
Doubtfire and things just snowballed
I did not expect ever
to be in movies I did not expect ever to
be headlining a movie I was a nerdy kid
I really was I I was not child star
materials like oh yeah there's me and
there's the Olsen twins you know they
were the popular girls and I was a drama
club nerd one of the emails you're
telling me that they kept dressing you
in pink and making you like super girly
you're like dude I wear like tomboy
clothes okay I wear Japanese that
happened all the time I mean I secretly
do love pink but it's not because I'm
girliest because I'm the reincarnation
of Oscar Wilde um but yeah when I was
when I was a kid I was a tomboy I had
three older brothers you know and we
were maybe we weren't really a sports
playing family we were more of a let's
talk about Star Wars family but I didn't
really want to be cutesy I I wanted to
be respected and they kept doing that
they kept saying oh yeah we're gonna
make you the next Shirley Temple we're
gonna do this we're gonna do that we're
gonna curl your hair and I felt kind of
objectified at times you know like oh
they they have to make me cute I know I
they I feel like a lot of that happened
in miracle and all of these different
critics would be saying god she's so
annoyingly cute and I would be thinking
yeah I know isn't that annoying I was
crossing my fingers for the day a role
become where where I could play a badass
never really seemed to happen though if
school the nostalgia critic pretty boy
hey it's true it's true I've become a
badass now that I'm an adult um long
time going
you've really wanted to go into acting
really sense childhood um what
essentially got you out of it at least
in terms of movies well there were a
couple things I I did a lot of movies
that were mostly kids movies my parents
always thought that there weren't enough
kids movies out there and I've said this
a bunch of times people have asked me
you know why were you in Thomas why are
you in a simple wish and my answer is
you know what I had to keep acting and
if you're you sort of do as a child
actor you have to keep going it's
inertia in a way and there can really
only be so many to kill a mockingbirds
if you're going to be a child actor a
lot of successful child actors I know
have been into some pretty terrible
movies and so and honestly I had a lot
of fun doing those Thomas was one of the
most fun times I've ever had in my life
just traveling and everybody on this set
was just so much fun it was
it was a really good time but I think I
had always known that I didn't want to
be an actor in fact the thing that I
liked most about performing when I was
little was telling stories there are
clips of me doing screen tests for
Doubtfire where I'm just telling stories
they wanted to you know see how I would
be with Robin and I told him a very
long-winded story about a little bunny
having an adventure and and it's really
funny at the end of it he whistles and
looks right into the camera and goes
we'll be right back so yeah writing was
really what I wanted to do I I wanted to
write before I could write and I wanted
to tell stories and the performing of it
was just something that was almost
secondary so I got a little older and I
thought you know film film wasn't as fun
anymore film I I wasn't playing the kind
of parts that I wanted to get and I was
also you know I was I was in awkward I
was an awkward preteen and they always
want teenagers to be playing free teens
and preteens to be playing kids and I
couldn't anymore additionally I also
discovered theater at this time it's
funny people I make the joke that you
know I I wanted to run away from the
film industry and be in community
theater and I did it felt so much more
like a big deal to me to get a part in
the play than it did in film I don't
know if it's just like an inherent
masochism or what but I love working for
things I like working hard I like
metaphorically speaking getting my hands
dirty and in film you don't really get
to see the payoff so much to sort of
separate from the end results until the
premiere so that disconnect that
disconnect I I didn't really enjoy so
much you essentially survived something
that a lot of child actors could not and
that's being a child actor for example I
have one friend who went out there and
he knew a few of the kids from high
school musical and they said that they
liked hanging out with him because he
treated them like actual kids what
advice would you have for not only child
actors but the parents of child actors
who are going into this I would say do
not push your child into acting do not
be the one to push your child into it
you know you can push your child to do
other things you can push your child to
take acting classes even if that's what
you insist I don't think I would do that
with my children but don't push them
into it let them make their own decision
let them keep the money that they've
made and save it for an education
because they do need an education and I
would also say that you have to think
about why you want to do it don't do it
to become famous being famous is is not
very fun for kids I found you know the
glamor kind of fades the glamour fades
quickly and you adapt to it even as a
kid it's the same thing with a lot of
gifted children where they will get so
much praise and be told so many times
you know this is that you are great you
are brilliant you are this that they
always feel like they have to rise to
that level for the rest of their lives
and I've seen that happen with people
who were told they were so brilliant
when they were young that they're always
feeling like they have to overcome it
later on I would say if you do want to
act the best thing to do I think is to
do like one or two films then go back to
real life you know have it be an
experience not not a career I would say
obviously they're always going to be
children doing this and personally I
cannot wait until we have you know the
CGI kids to fill in from the actual
child thing they're already starting did
you see the new Twilight there's a CGI
baby Lindsay asked me if I wanted to see
it and I said I refused to pay for the
fact which is embarrassing because I
actually have a friend who is in
Twilight um I love it Twilight is so bad
you still won't go see it even though a
friend isn't it I'm like exactly I still
won't see it because I have some moral
issues with it maybe we could buy
tickets for something else and sneak in
but I'm not putting my money towards
that you seem to have sort of this very
um when you speak of it certainly
compared to other child actors I mean
you seem to have these very fond
memories of it you know the very
optimistic look where they're ever times
where let's say you did not have that
point of view baby things were not so
much fun and things were too much and it
was just unpleasant memories and what do
you think caused that I think I I do I
do have a lot of regrets I think
sometimes if things were hard I know
working on a simple wish I don't I don't
really remember but I think of my
behavior at the time onset and I feel
really bad because I know that my you
know my mother had recently died and I
was very upset
and I just wasn't in a good place and I
should not have been filming a movie and
I I feel really bad for those things
it's really I'm really mostly I'm really
mostly embarrassed about the things that
I've that I've done and the memories
that I have like oh I could have done
that better I could have put in more
effort I could have worked that I'm sort
of a born perfectionist
I remember having an audition for a
movie where my parents got divorced and
I was you know begging to be to leave
with my father and they kept making me
go through it again and again we're
basing my father my the father character
says you know no I I don't want you and
so I was just you know crying and
sobbing in these auditions all the time
and I thought nothing of it and I look
back on that now and I remember going
back on callbacks for that several times
I know and they had me crying and
screaming over and over again and I was
thinking that's kind of messed up you
know I I know it's I know it's acting
and I they knew it was acting and
putting me through that again and again
was I can imagine was probably kind of
taxing for a nine-year-old did they
treat you like a child like you know in
a good way like you know yet you are a
child and there's rules and such or did
they treat you more like a little adult
or how were you treated it varied really
I could tell when people were I could
tell when people were being
condescending I could tell that and I
didn't like it I didn't like it when
people said I was cute I thought that
that was a condescending term now I
don't mind it a lot had kids or had
worked with kids before so they knew
they knew what to expect and some people
all did did treat me like little adult
but the people who actually saw who I
was as a child were probably the ones
that I got along best with Danny DeVito
allowed me to have so much fun he
allowed me to be really creative and we
played games and I helped design a doll
that's in the movie now you're saying
that you're a big fan of writing I
notice you still write you have the mara
Wilson rights stuff blog mare uh tell me
about your writing what what is it that
you so enjoy about it and outside of the
mara Wilson right stuff blog are there
are places where they can see your
writing I started out writing plays and
some you know performance pieces at NYU
and
I really liked plays because it was all
dialogue it was all the way that people
talked and as a lifelong eavesdropper
dialogue has come easily to me I'm
trying to get this play that I've been
working on forever it's a play called
sheeple and it's it's about teenagers
and culture and it's kind of a
coming-of-age story I think I actually
want to break into young adult novel
writing I have a couple of ideas that
I'm working on right now for books and
none of them are paranormal romances and
I work with teenagers and kids and I've
always worked with kids
most of my jobs have been working with
kids and with young people and I find
the way that they think about the world
to be very interesting now outside of
writing and hanging out with Lindsay
Ellis Oh with most of your time well I
work for a nonprofit organization called
public color it's a really cool
organization I've worked with a bunch of
nonprofits and public color is really
amazing you go into New York City Public
Schools and we repaint the schools
because I don't know if you've ever seen
pictures of New York City public schools
but they're pretty depressing looking we
go into the schools and then work with
the students in those schools to repaint
them and work on design and the kids get
to vote on what colors they want to
paint it they get support and I get a
family and they get free food and then
we also kids that we actually induct
into the program and those kids get
scholarship help and mentoring and they
go to workshops during the week and go
big on college tours it's a really cool
organization and I have met so many
amazing kids through this program so
many brilliant kids who are you know now
going on to college and living their
lives so yeah if anybody wants to
support or or donate it or find out more
about public color you can go ahead and
go to public color org you can look up
volunteering if you're in the New York
area I've come out on a Saturday and
helped us paint
oh that's wonderful Congrats on that
I've worked for a lot of nonprofits and
it's one that I really believe in
something I will ask simply because
people will kill me if I don't the only
review that I said I was going to do at
one point as the nostalgia critic and
actually decided not to I actually
crossed it off the list even though I
announced it was the mathilde review and
it's a film that
and as you probably know I'm not a fan
of but I know so many people are and I
know you enjoy the film too as someone
who just sees it as such a mean ugly
movie what is the attraction just from
someone who does not get it that what do
you get out of it outside of obviously
being in it it is it is exceptionally
dark and you're right you're right it is
it is exceptionally dark but there's
something I think I had a history with a
book - one of my earliest memories is my
mom took me to a school one day because
she was actually reading the book out
loud to a classroom and you know
becoming the Trunchbull and not quite
understanding what this was but really
liking it it's just absurd enough that
there's a level of distance with it you
know you were talking about writing a
young adult book I don't know I could
see a sequel to Matilda maybe dabbling a
little bit in the supernatural they're
you asking me all the time why are you
not doing them until the two and they
don't understand that a that you know
it's based on a book roll dolly no may
rest in peace is he's no longer a lie
actress you have total control
I know exactly and that's another thing
two actors don't really don't have that
much control and I don't think people
realize that
a film is very much it's been said a
director's medium in fact I have a hard
time telling what an actor is good or
not because I don't know I don't know
what choices they made and watch which
choices the directors told them to make
no but I'm saying if they made if we
made like a Matilda to poster you know
Matilda's all grown up or and kicking
ass or something like that if people
want to make that kind of you know mock
presentation then that's that's fine
with me
actually somebody the other day told me
that they really liked Miracle on Elm
Street and I am just dying for that to
be made I would love to see that made
well you know now there's gonna be after
seeing this there's gonna be people out
there that are gonna make Miracle on Elm
Street and Matilda two posters they're
gonna give Matilda like machine gun or
sorry go ahead
I can see this you have my blessing two
questions I like to end interviews with
you know they're polar opposites um
whether it be professional or personal
uh what would you say is one of the
toughest things you ever had to go
through and how did you get through it I
think undoubtedly the most difficult
things that I've had to deal with in my
life was my mother dying and I'm not
going to go into detail about that right
now but I will say that what really
seemed to help me at the time was having
a creative outlet that's something that
has always helped me and I was writing
stories at the time I was writing
scripts I was writing plays and I look
back on what I wrote now and I realize
just how therapeutic it was and it was
interesting to me to see that and I've
also had you know I've also had some
like when I when I've gone through
something rough I found I found myself
becoming more inspired you know I went
through a really rough breakup a few
years ago and I started writing more and
more and more after that and it fueled
it in a way it fueled it and I was able
to channel my frustration and my sadness
into something and I think that's really
you know one of the best things that you
can do I think
channeling it into something always
works whether it's you know whether it's
exercise whether it's helping others
that's another thing that I've always
loved to do I've always I've always done
stuff with charities and nonprofit
organizations you know and when when I'm
sad about my own life or I'm frustrated
with the way things are going and
usually I'm pretty happy with the way
things are but when I am reaching out
and doing things for others as corny as
it may sound actually helps a lot that
doesn't sound corny at all yeah well I'm
glad you know it's it's you're a
good-hearted Midwesterner though Doug
I'm a cold-hearted New Yorker so uh so I
I think that that's something that's
always that's something that's always
made me feel good is reaching out and
helping others and assisting others
where they need help and and also having
a creative outlet those are things that
have gotten me through a lot well you
might just answer my final question here
again whether it be professional or
personal what is the one thing you are
the most proud of that you've ever done
probably
yeah it would either it would either
have to be you know the work that I've
done uh you know the actual like
hands-on work I've done whether it
through charity work when I was a kid or
the nonprofit's that I worked with as an
adult and I've worked with a couple
those things were very important to me
another thing that's been a kind of a
game-changer in my life was a piece I
wrote when I was in let's see my second
year of college I wrote and performed a
piece that was it was very personal but
it was very honest and that's one thing
that I really like I really I think I
think you know vulnerable is the new
cynical man I think allowing yourself
you know allowing yourself to be honest
and to be open you know there's a lot of
there's a lot of sarcastic humor out
there and I think if it's done well case
in point
um that that I can really appreciate
that but when it's just you know kind of
you know mean for the sake of being mean
I don't I I can't appreciate it it gets
very old very fast I think it's very
lazy so I wrote this piece when I was 19
and I performed it and it was a solo
piece just about about like my life and
my family and and afterwards you know
people were coming up to me with tears
in their eyes saying you know I could
relate to this and it was funny because
the more personal that I had made it the
more people seem to interact with it and
that was a piece that really taught me
okay you know I can do this I can write
something and there is an audience out
there that is going to be willing to
connect to this and I've looked back on
it now and it's not the best thing I've
written but it meant something it meant
something to me and I think you have to
look back in the process I think you
have to look back at what life was like
at that time and what I knew about
writing at that time and I think looking
back on it it's something that makes me
immensely proud for where I was at the
time and it also opened up these doors
and showed me wow okay this is really
what I want to do I can actually reach
out and I can do these things and this
is what I want to do for the rest of my
life
Maura I can't explain how honored and
ecstatic I am to have you as my very
first guest as
I had to say thank you so much for
having a good sense of humor oh yeah so
much good has come of it I think so much
good has come of it and it's it's been a
lot of fun and you know I was watching
I've gotten into it myself you know I
was watching uh I watched Lindsey's
Freddy got fingered video today I've
gotten unum I came home and my roommate
was watching her reality bites you know
it was we've all kind of converted I
think so so thank you for that and and
it's it's always fun every time I do
something with channel awesome so so
thank you for giving me the opportunity
well thank you so much again I am Doug
Walker this was the awesome Morrow
Wilson and we shall talk with you later
you